so yeah so let's talk about your your
plural series question where are
founders right for not allowing women to
vote oh yeah I don't think women should
vote oh shoot sorry you don't think
women should vote no why is that I think
um right now there's selective service
for men which means um you have to be
like basically drafted it's it's like
the new version of the draft if there's
a type of War you have to you know go
fight and I think that's fair like if
you're living in a country like yeah you
should defend it but the issue is women
don't have that same right so why do we
still get the same Freedom like that's
why women didn't vote for before like
they always spin it because okay well
also they didn't want it they also women
chose we didn't want to they didn't want
to vote because then they had to be like
police officers firemen and do all the
stuff they're like I don't want to do
that stuff like we're good but that's
the thing feminism is always we want all
the freedom without the responsibility
that comes with it the responsibility is
selective service so now you just want
special treatment and so I think unless
we want to do that I I think we should
have it it's never going to happen so
it's kind of just like you know in what
world and I also read the
anti-suffragettes like actual writings
because I couldn't figure out when I
first heard it I was like that's crazy
like why didn't women want to vote and
they were talking about how this is the
beginning of the breakdown of the family
they're trying to break up the family
and that's what happened because you're
not supposed to it's supposed to be like
a one-man one like a husband and wife
they're supposed to become one and
nuclear family's gone yeah destroyed
correct but that's done through politics
too Linda B Johnson came in and kind of
painted the whole liberal mindset and
ruined and took all the the fathers out
of the homes you know here we'll give
you money more kids you have we won't
let the father see your kid yeah Katie
said uh something about uh women vote on
emotions yeah and that's that's what I
think
I gave women the right to vote because
we're much more susceptible to
propaganda and propaganda started in the
20s when they like like radio basically
started and so basically you can you can
tell a girl a sob story you know like oh
there's an 11 year old who can't get an
abortion because she was graped or what
you know and then the women run to the
polls because that's like we just think
on emotion and so I think that like
honestly I think that they gave women
the right to vote to use us as a tool
and single women overwhelmingly vote
Democrat you know that's interesting you
said that
it's interesting do you think that most
women are are
feminists or conservative I mean oh I I
say feminists because feminists are
liberal Democrats I think I think single
women tend to become feminists really
yeah I mean I actually think a lot of
conservatives are actually feminists
they just don't know it uh too so like
they like they the voting thing they
wouldn't even right I actually I think I
got Candace Owens red pilled on voting
because she put out a video talking
about voting after I started talking
about I don't want to say I did it you
probably did I think I did you probably
did but like that's the thing like and
even the conservatives will still tell
the men man up be more be more when it's
like well what about the women yeah yeah
that's it's interesting because I have
the same philosophy here that that I was
like a pro-trump supporter right I
walked through the airports I had I have
another YouTube it's still up there but
I'm not gonna say what it is but it went
viral so I had a tank top that said
blacks for trumps right blacks blacks
for Trump and I went through LAX San
Francisco airport with my Mexican
girlfriend right it went by viral right
and it was more of a political YouTube
and I found that in the black community
we were still absorbed with the whole we
were in Doctrine in the whole notion
that Democrats were there to help so I
have a couple philosophies it's like hey
I don't need help I never needed a
handout I went to schools that said I
wasn't black enough I went to schools
that said I wasn't white enough I mean
I'm stuck in the middle I had to deal
with both sides right and so the whole
point was
we growing up I grew up liberal then I
owned businesses and I became a
conservative I voted right I don't say
I'm a conservative person but I vote
right does that make sense yeah um but I
say I'm alt right all right okay there
you go alt tab I'm just kidding but but
you see what I'm saying I'm a capitalist
right I believe in free enterprise uh
the opportunity to own and run a
business America capitalism lower taxes
on people all that stuff but what I
found out about the the minorities is
now they're waking up in America
and I don't mean woke they didn't go
that they went they went right they're
like wait a minute you didn't do
anything for us you kindness and they
voted on their emotions like women do
and now they're like wait a minute
America's in the in the we're we're in
bad shape I mean all the countries are
moving away from our dollar right so now
what I said they have left is they have
the the alphabet kids left
lgtbq right trans queer gays and then
they have the feminists that's all they
have left for the vote so it's
interesting you said that because I find
that and I talked to a lot of um
successful black people successful
Hispanics and I asked them I said why
did you think Trump was bad
but they all ended up coming to the same
point that said they were going off
their emotions off of what people were
saying or the perception right the
propaganda right are you with me yes and
propaganda is what is what wins
elections but when you take a step back
like Tucker Carlson walked away or was
fired but walked away right and you step
outside of the Matrix as you would I
would Tate or anybody else we're in The
Matrix but we can step out and go no
this is what's really going on and we
voice our opinions we're
ostracized for it isn't that funny but
we see the reality and so I always tell
people look take your emotions out of it
take a step back follow the money see
what's really going on and you'll get
the result right yeah so
um and you know I just think that if
people will do that I think they're
going to have a better outcome let's
talk about low coach woke culture how
does that worked for you I mean you got
a lot of do you see the changes
happening in London is it as bad as
America with
yeah I mean I I just think it gets more
divisive every year to oh well I
actually think maybe the Trump election
was Peak divisiveness you think it was
well I think
I think of a more crazy time than when
Trump first ran like I just think that
was like the peak of woke yeah that was
like when Ben Shapiro destroys social
justice Warrior
I loved does Ben come back to college
campuses I'm begging you
um no it's it's crazy I think most women
are feminists to be honest whether they
know it or not really yeah why is that
though why do you feel that
um what happened
I mean I just think
I think we're naturally more liberal
like women
yeah like I think unless you have strong
men around you like we naturally
gravitate to be more liberal because
we're more like caring compassionate I
guess you could say like you always want
to take care of the oh the poor person
that you know is
needs help from the government whatever
okay more compassionate yeah as a woman
should be right yeah you feel that way
so I have this okay now I want to get
into this because this is an interesting
question
in our space we all talk about this
Kevin talked about it Rolo Michael I
don't want to use names because maybe
they haven't
um loyalty with men
Jay Waller right okay he talks about
this and I'm not begging on him he's a
good dude like I like all I have beef
with nobody but we all have I think all
the guys all the men we all agree 90 or
95 with each other right I don't think
we're all on the like sneako Tate and if
we all line this up as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible